brick and mortar businesses who want to
scale what you do is you actually do it
through mergers and Acquisitions and
it's faster it costs you less money than
opening on your own so if you're a dry
cleaning business and there are other
dry cleaning businesses that have the
equipment that have the everything they
don't have the brand they don't have the
sales system the market they have the
pricing right you can buy the ones that
are struggling for almost nothing when I
realize this my things are my fourth
location I just bought I got it for free
the amount of cost to just fix it and
Rebrand it little compared to opening
from scratch if you've ever heard of
Waste Management the huge trash company
he grew that entirely through an A so he
would go to a guy and say hey you've got
a trash route just sell our finance to
me I'll give you no money and I'll pay
you over the next five years and people
are like sure and he just accumulated
locations and routes that's how he did
it